- Please welcome Soman Chainani.
(crowd cheering)
- So, meet everybody, I
don't know if y'all met.
Um, I always love having
like a mixture of people
that might never be together in one place.
That's my favorite part.
- He was my Friday night date.
When I was in high school.
I have no social life.
- Did he put out?
(laughing)
- X Files was my thing
every, every Friday.
- I Remember.
- Can I just say, you gorgeous.
- Oh god.
- Oh, you so good lookin'.
Geez.
- Thank you
- I just wanted to
compliment you. I'm sorry.
I'm somebody's black
mama, but you gorgeous.
(laughing)
(clapping)
- My mom is going to appreciate that.
My, my mom's upset I'm still single.
So she's gonna, that's
going to be a calling card
she's gonna send out to every
Indian in the tri-state area.
- Just a reminder, you could
be in a horrible relationship.
So single ain't that bad.
- I'm happy.
- Um, I didn't even know this was a thing,
but you studied fairytales at Harvard.
So I could have gone to Harvard.
(laughing)
I feel like wait, what?
Like, fairytales?
- Yeah, they didn't know
it was a thing either,
but I grew up at Disney baby.
Like I was the kid whose parents,
when they couldn't deal with them,
like plop them in front
of Alice in Wonderland or
Cinderella.
- Absolutely, Lion King all the way down.
The way that, you know,
parents use Tik ToK and YouTube today.
Like Disney was our thing.
I never stick an iPad
in front of my children.
Others do.
- But, you know, so I knew
all those stories by heart,
but then I went to college and
ended up sort of by chance in
this fairytales class.
- Yeah.
- And I thought we were gonna
learn the Disney versions.
Cause I thought Disney invented
all these stories, you know?
(laughing)
Cause I didn't know any better.
And then, you learn the original
stories and you're like,
these stories are so rich and
dangerous and provocative and
the evil guy wins half the
time and the good guy and
there's, there's an edge to it.
I felt like, like my mind was blown.
I'm like my whole childhood is
based on this lie. You know?
Like how do I,
how can I bring these
stories to other people?
And I think that's where this
new book came from this idea
of like, why can't kids grow up with
that kind of danger in their fairytale.
So it feels more like,
you don't know who's
going to win at the end.
And I think that's what
I wanted to do with it
is give evil an equal chance.
So that's why even in
"School for Good and Evil"
and in "Beast and Beauty",
there's always a balance beast
and beauty, good and evil.
- I love that this is your slogan.
Give evil an equal chance.
(laughing)
- Listen, I wish I could
go back to high school
and run for every election on that.
- Oh well Soman's first book,
"The school for Good and Evil"
is now an upcoming movie
with Charlize Theron
and Kerry Washington. That's crazy goal.
(crowd clapping)
So, what was it like, like seeing your,
your dream and your vision and you know,
all your words come to life on screen?
- I mean, I almost had a heart attack,
I think like when you first,
cause I was in quarantine
before I went onto set.
So you're alone in a room
for multiple days being like,
okay, visualizing it, being
like be cool, be cool.
And as soon as you get on
set, not cool, you know.
- It's Kerry Washington
and Charlize Theron, yeah.
- And also, it's Paul Feig, the director,
and he's just visionary,
you know, "Bridesmaids",
"Freaks and Geeks" by.
And he doesn't like green
screen and pixels and just
everything being computer generated.
So he built the entire freaking
school for good and evil.
Like, you go onto set
and it is this massive
like complex of the school.
And so to go in there,
and I had spent 10 years
writing these books.
10 years of like all my
unconscious and everything
suddenly projected out.
I kept having these like little
psychic breaks where I kept
forgetting it was my kinda universe.
- You're like, who created
this? They're amazing!
- It happened once where
I went to the costume department
and I was like, oh, that's so weird,
there's a character named
Hort in my books, how strange.
Like, just like totally
- Out of body
- Out of body complete, you know.
But, um, I just think it's gonna be,
it's a huge movie.
It's one of Netflix's biggest movies ever.
And I just think it's,
it gives them that kind of
Harry Potter esque franchise,
but this time a little more representative
a little bit more inclusive.
You know, and I think it's just,
it's a great movie for our times.